when war veteran frank castle returns
home from the horrors of battle all he
wants to do is be with his wife and kids
but after they're gunned down in a mob
shootout frank dedicates his life to
vengeance as the punisher a man with big
guns and an enviable 5 o'clock shadow
the punisher has been one of Marvel's
most compelling and complex characters
for decades for proof here are 10
Punisher facts you may not know the
exterminator the Punisher is best known
these days for his interactions with
daredevil but he began his comfo career
as a spider-man villain in the amazing
spider-man number 129 Punisher is hired
by The Jackal
to hunt for the notorious vigilante wall
crawler claiming that spider-man had
killed Norman Osborn in a previous fight
when in fact Osborn accidentally killed
himself creator Jerry Conway always
intended Frank Castle to first appear as
a villain only to eventually become a
hero well an extreme antihero obviously
the two made amends before Spidey got
completely punished the assassin Jerry
Conway Punishers creator originally
wanted to name the character the
assassin Stanley vetoed that idea
thinking it had too many harsh
connotations for what was essentially a
picture book for kids then Lee had an
idea years earlier he created an
unmemorable robot named The Punisher who
was one of Galactus his henchmen Lee
suggested that Conway used the robots
name
Conway took it because well you don't
say no to Stanley he's been the Punisher
ever since the executioner he starred in
over 600 books which have sold well over
200 million copies worldwide
except that we're not talking about the
Punisher these stats belong to Mac Bolin
a fictional character created by Don
Pendleton and if Mac Bolin didn't exist
Punisher might not have either created
in 1968 Mac Bolin is a Vietnam vet who
comes home from war only to watch his
family dive right before his eyes at the
hands of the Mafia which sparks a
lifelong obsession with vengeance
he earns the nickname the executioner
drives around on a weapons filled van
and keeps a war journal somehow Marvel
hasn't been sued into oblivion for
copyright infringement Archie and Eminem
get punished The Punisher is one of
those characters who's great on his own
but even better in a team-up like that
time he saved an
from an assassin hired by a group of
parents who hated his music published in
2009 in a two-part miniseries creatively
called
eminem / the punisher frank introduces
himself by killing Eminem's entourage
later eminem takes a chainsaw to the
villain barracuda and everything was
just as violent as you'd expect as
strange as it was all seemed natural
compared to 1994's archie meets the
punisher where our antihero chases a
drug dealer to squeaky-clean Riverdale
of course the drug dealer looks almost
exactly like archie so cue the comical
mix ups and mishaps the fun and games
end when the drug dealer kidnaps
Veronica but not to worry
Punisher saves the day and even sticks
around to chaperone the school dance
bombing the box office
Punisher has had three big screen
adaptations and two of them were massive
financial disasters 2008 s Punisher war
zone and the 1989 Dolph Lundgren
Punisher movie are the biggest bombs and
Marvel movie history how big you say
even bigger than Howard the Duck a movie
universally regarded as one of the worst
of all time no one laughs at a master of
quack fool yes even worse than that
dirty laundry Tom Jane turned down the
role of The Punisher a couple of times
because he didn't see himself as a hero
but after finally playing him in 2004 he
was hooked he walked away from the
proposed sequel due to creative
differences but he loved playing the
character so much that he starred in an
independent Punisher short film called
dirty laundry even washing black
t-shirts is a bloody adventure for the
Punisher Captain America's secret
admirer
Punisher doesn't really care about
anyone in the Marvel Universe with the
exception of Captain America cap was a
fellow soldier and the pureness of his
moral compass is unrivaled Punisher
actually respects cap so much that
Punisher has at times outright refused
to fight him when Captain America was
temporarily dead in the comics Punisher
changed his costume to a red white and
blue theme to honor his fallen hero
Frank Castle kills everything in a
one-shot alternate universe comic titled
Punisher kills the Marvel Universe The
Punisher did well just that in this
what-if type tale
Castle
wife and kids are killed during a fierce
superhero battle Punisher kills Cyclops
on the spot for his mistake which gets
Punisher locked away except on the way
to the prison he meets a group of others
who were disfigured during the Marvel
Universe's countless destructive
superhero fights
Frank Castle gets everything he needs to
kill every last character in the Marvel
Universe saving daredevil for last when
the deed is done
Punisher turns the gun on to himself but
it's not just superheros he's got it in
for in Punisher the end another
non-canon story Frank Castle is one of
the last remaining humans on earth after
a nuclear holocaust Frank tracks down
the last of the survivors to kill them
since they were the ones responsible for
the destruction of the human race again
Punisher kills everyone then chooses
himself as the final victim setting
himself on fire and wandering into the
wasteland finally ending humanity's
cycle of violence once and for all so
how does all of this add up well in 2011
Marvel Comics Editor Stephen whacker
crunched the numbers from 1974 to 2011
Punisher had killed exactly forty eight
thousand five hundred and two people
yeah he's kind of a monster in fact he's
literally a monster Punisher has been
killed and resurrected as monstrous
versions of his former self not once but
twice in the late 90s miniseries
Punisher purgatory Frank Castle kills
himself and that is brought back to life
as a demon hunter with two guns that
fire heavenly power or something like
that then in 2010 after being
dismembered by Wolverines son Punishers
body parts fall into the hands of the
vampire and Dave Navarro look-alike
Morbius who reassembles Frank Castle and
abused his corpse with life
turning him into Frank and Castle truly
one of the best comic book names ever
except for maybe Fin Fang Foom iconic
The Punisher skull logo means more to
people in real life than it does to him
hundreds of Iraqi soldiers wear the
Punisher signature skull somewhere on
their gear it's the symbol they've
chosen to represent their fight against
Isis
the trend has been going on for a while
but it was reinforced by Chris Kyle the
subject of the movie American sniper who
wore the symbol during his tour of duty
that cartoony elongated skull has become
a definitive rallying cry for
anti-terror forces in the Middle East
Frank Castle would be proud thanks for
watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know what
punisher facts you would have wanted to
see on the list